as the harvest continues on america's
farms we are reminded
that even the biggest melons and
pumpkins started out as
tiny seeds it's a similar journey for
one of
the nation's largest produce suppliers
it all began
when a teenager named sarah frye took
over her parents failing farm
and built it into a multi-state
phenomenon
she's telling her story in the book the
growing season how i built a new life
and saved an american farm which was
published just this week
life on the hill and in southern
illinois
was very it was very isolated at times
it was very harsh
it was brutal at times sarah frye didn't
exactly have a typical childhood
growing up on a family farm with her
parents and four older brothers
in southern illinois we spent a lot of
time hunting for our food harvesting the
food that you know
we consumed i remember the first time i
saw the thermostat
on a wall and i thought wow this magic
box why am i cutting wood every day you
know to heat
to heat our home i knew it was unusual
but i enjoyed the work i enjoyed the
family bonds
i was very very close with my brothers
growing up
and all of the bad was cancelled out by
the good and the love and the support
that i
felt with them it is those same memories
good
and bad that fry shares in her new book
the growing season parts of her story
like her first hunting excursion with
her
father and brothers where as a little
girl she just wanted to prove that she
belonged
when i shot my first rabbit it was such
a big deal you know they were cheering
for me and i grabbed the rabbit and i
held it in the air and i'm like see
you'll never leave me behind again
first shot right first shot one shot
done
and from that moment forward i thought i
was the greatest hunter
in in in the world i didn't know it at
the time but uh
the the rabbit was actually already dead
so
they had let me believe that i had
killed it and i think that that was one
of those
confidence building exercises that
happened
at a very early age it was that
confidence sarah then used
selling melons with her mom as a small
girl
i was able to you know make deals
talk talk to adults and and sell things
and that was so much fun for me it was
freedom
at age 15 sarah moved out of her parents
house
at 16 she had her own melon selling
business
and at 17 with the family farm in
financial distress
she secured a loan and bought it for 50
thousand dollars
i never had a desire to stay here on the
farm everything that i had done
up until that very very moment was to
leave
and literally in a matter of seconds a
moment
i made the decision that i was going to
stay
i didn't do it because i loved the land
or the farm
i didn't because i loved my family
i knew that if i left too
there would be nothing left here for us
to come home to
while her brothers would help with the
business it was sarah leading the charge
the turning point for frye farms a
produce distribution deal
with walmart i met this woman who was
setting her office up
and she happened to be a produce buyer
i'm like
19 years old i have a pickup truck i'm
kind of still a one-woman show
in less than 30 minutes she gave me
you know orders for semi-truckloads
worth of
fruits and vegetables i had the
confidence in that moment
to shake her hand and say i can do this
but then when i walked out i thought i
don't own a semi i don't even know how
to drive one
and now i have to figure out how i'm
going to deliver
she didn't just deliver she got the
attention of harvard business school
which made sarah's fry farms walmart
deal the subject of a negotiating case
study
they would ask the question well how did
you do this and at the time i was like
well i don't know i just did it you know
everything in my life i just got used to
like knocking down doors and you know
showing up that study forced me um to
have to think about
some of the techniques that that i had
learned and then it took me
right back to some of the most difficult
moments
of my childhood different moments in my
life
that i had to have courage i had to
negotiate or i had to take a stand
and then i started to understand it
better myself
after starting with 80 acres in illinois
frye farms has grown into thousands
in seven states growing fresh fruits and
vegetables
and there is one in particular sarah has
become known for
you are known as america's pumpkin queen
how did that come about
pumpkins are the first crop that i
started to grow here so
i fell in love with pumpkins very early
on that particular crop was
also part of my salvation what helped me
save this farm and to you know
build the business allow my four older
brothers to come home
and join me in the business so i'm very
fond
of the pumpkins sarah is also fond of
what's called the ugly fruit using the
produce normally rejected because it
doesn't meet the right visual standards
for juices
one of fry farms latest ventures for
sustainability
and profitability you're incorporating
products that might otherwise be wasted
you're ultimately doing
the right thing for the farm the right
thing for the planet and then you're
also doing the right thing for consumers
because you're providing them
with really healthy clean simple
delicious beverages
that ability to look past the surface
imperfections and find the good or
greater purpose appears to be both the
essence of sarah fry
and the growing season what do you hope
that people get out of this book
i hope that what people get out of the
book is
is an inspiration that the book helps
them to see
through life's imperfections and
hardships
it's like right now everything that
we're going through as a country with
covet just
know that there's a brighter season on
the other side of this
and to have the optimism of a farmer
because the growing seasons that are
fallow
can teach us just as much as the growing
seasons that are bountiful
we're actually learning some good stuff
and we're going to get through it and
there's a brighter growing season to
come
and sarah had to send us some of the
bounty fry farms so that you could have
it in person
honestly this book is inspiring she
actually writes it in attributes it
wants
more girls to steal thunder is what she
says the idea of champion where you are
she really learned to be tough growing
up in those tough circumstances on the
farm
and it's what's been in the back of her
mind every step of the way as she's
grown this business and raising two sons
as well right now
she saw opportunity and she saw it so
young
gosh she just tried some of this
watermelon she said it's delicious
it's tremendous stuff from her worry
about how she
shot the rabbit right and her family her
brothers and her dad knew they had the
rabbit in the bush sort of said is that
a rabbit over there
instead of saying you're great and you
can do anything she shot the rabbit she
believed in herself at a young age